bonjour bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
émission de parlement hebdo aux
compagnies cette semaine de delphine
gérard bonjour delphine dans l'actualité
politique et parlementaire cette semaine
il ya eu des députés sommet d'avancer au
pas de charge sur les dernières réformes
annoncées par nicolas sarkozy
au menu d'ici le 9 mars une loi sur le
logement est un collectif budgétaire
avec notamment la tva sociale
le président a reçu les parlementaires
de la majorité pour dissiper les états
d'âme vis quoi de neuf cette semaine sur
l'échiquier des présidentiables jean
pierre chevènement qui retire sa
candidature et marine le pen qui vient
devant le sénat dénoncer un système de
parrainage qui l'empêchent dit-elle
d'avoir ses 500 signatures
marine le pen qui a même fait une
incursion à l'intérieur du sénat enfin
le logement au coeur de la campagne
cette semaine quatre candidats ont signé
le contrat social de la fondation abbé
pierre qui a publié un rapport aux
chiffres toujours plus alarmant 1,6
million de personnes seraient non une
très mal logés et avec nous aujourd'hui
pour commenter l'actualité politique et
parlementaire de cette semaine delphine
batho bonjour bonjour vous êtes députée
socialiste des deux sèvres vous avez
d'ailleurs succédé à ségolène royal à
cette fonction élective et
vous êtes depuis octobre depuis la fin
de la primaire socialiste porte parole
de françois hollande
est-ce que ça a été facile de passer de
ségolène royal à françois hollande
ça a été très très naturel c'est la
continuité d'un engagement et aussi d'un
rassemblement puisque une des forces
nombreuses de françois hollande
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il est un
rassembleur et que se retrouve
aujourd'hui unis autour de lui toute une
équipe avec bien sûr martine aubry
ségolène royal laurent fabius arnaud
montebourg et bien d'autres mais aussi
toute une nouvelle génération très
dynamique avec des gens comme najat
vallaud belkacem guillaume bachelay
bernard cazeneuve voilà des gens sont
moins connus mais avec une nouvelle
génération unité que ségolène royal
n'avait pas réussi à faire en 2007 vous
expliquer qui nous sommes en que cette
fois-ci françois hollande a réussi à
faire cette unité peut-être justement
parce qu'on a les leçons du passé et de
ses divisions qui nous ont coûté si cher
mais aussi parce que je crois c'est
c'est la nature de de françois hollande
d'être un rassembleur mais je crois
aussi surtout parce que tout le monde a
un sens aujourd'hui des responsabilités
une envie de gagner qui permet de mettre
de côté ce qui a été bien des défauts de
la gauche et puis je crois surtout que
c'est le processus des primaires
citoyennes qui permet aujourd'hui 7 7
unités cette force qui est en train de
se mettre en mouvement autour de
françois hollande c'est le fait que sa
candidature résulte d'un processus dans
lequel plus de trois millions de
personnes sont venues sont venus voter
donc il a cette légitimité qui dépasse
ce qui était parfois les querelles
internes au parti socialiste mais on
apprend que ségolène royal va faire
campagne à sedan trop l'ambiance à faire
des déplacements bien sûr les plus fâché
donc lhi le bourget n'était pas très
content de ne pas être dans le film ça
va l'appeler elle a fait une remarque
qui était humaine mais compréhensive
d'ailleurs les choses ont été rectifiés
mais bien sûr elle est pleinement
engagée comme vous avez vu hier soir
martine aubry à la télévision laurent
fabius qui fait un certain nombre de
déplacements internationaux et en effet
mardi prochain ségolène royal tiendra un
meeting à marseille et à l'heure à
l'occasion aussi de s'adresser en
particulier aux citoyens
de banlieue qui ont les cadres ont donné
au cours de ces cinq dernières années
oui vous resté proche d'elle pardon vous
resté proche d'elle bien loin cei g1j un
lien indéfectible avec ségolène royal
puisque si je suis aujourd'hui député de
la république française c'est parce
qu'elle a fait le choix de transmettre à
une nouvelle génération
elle a fait le choix du non cumul des
mandats et de se l'appliquer à elle même
donc je lui dois beaucoup
est-ce qu'elle brille toujours la
présidence de l'assemblée nationale je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on est en pleine
campagne électorale on sait que la
confiance des français se mérite que
nous devons conquérir cette confiance
donc on n'est pas dans une répartition
des responsabilités même si c'est une
belle idée
en effet un jour ça puisse être une
femme qui soit présidente de l'assemblée
nationale
il vient d'être une bête on va passer
ensemble au crible de l'actualité de la
semaine on va commencer une fois n'est
pas coutume directement par le mardi
quand le discours présidentiel du
dimanche rebondi dans l'hémicycle mardi
jour des questions au gouvernement
séance très attendu après l'intervention
l'avant veille de nicolas sarkozy devant
16 millions de téléspectateurs sans
surprise ces socialistes sont montés au
créneau avec pour cibles privilégiées la
tva sociale qui a déjà ses surnoms tva
anti sociale ou encore tv à sarkozy
compte-rendu d'ahmed thèse hier à
l'assemblée l'opposition s'est mise en
ordre de bataille
c'est possible la tva sociale proposée
par nicolas sarkozy pour améliorer la
compétitivité des entreprises
à gauche on dénonce une tva anti sociale
monsieur le premier ministre après me
travailler plus pour gagner plus qui n'a
été qu'un travailler plus pour gagner
moins
c'est désormais travailler moins pour
gagner encore moi et pour payer encore
plus d'impôts
avec le premier ministre ne prendra pas
la parole sur le sujet il laisse le soin
au porte parole du gouvernement de
répondre aux attaques de la gauche
valérie pécresse qui rassure la hausse
de 1,6 point de la tva ne va pas
entraîner une hausse générale des prix
quant à la hausse de la tva dont vous
parlez dès lors que les prix des
produits français baisseront cette
hausse de la tva ne sera pas
mécaniquement répercuter en hausse des
prix au parti socialiste c'est décidé on
va mener la bataille parlementaire
jusqu'au bout contre les nouvelles
mesures annoncées par nicolas sarkozy le
patron du groupe socialiste dénoncent un
passage en force
c'est pas une petite mesure c'est du
lourd gouvernement veut passer en france
nous nous mèneront la bataille
parlementaire pour montrer qu'il ya une
autre voie possible
dans deux semaines les députés
commenceront à examiner le budget
rectificatif 2012
la hausse de la tva et la baisse des
cotisations patronales des débats à
l'assemblée qui s'annonce houleux alors
delphine batho c'est un marathon qu'on
va vous demander à vous parlementaire
d'ici le 9 mars fin de la session
il faut botter un collectif budgétaire
il faut voter une nouvelle loi sur le
logement
on suppose que vous députés socialistes
vous allez faire traîner cette
discussion à coups d'amendements
nous ne sommes pas là pour faire de
l'obstruction nous allons nous battre
pour notre heurter voilement terre la
mission que les électeurs nous ont
confié qu'ils aient de faire le travail
de députés de l'opposition donc nous
allons combattre cette disposition mais
pas en faisant de l'obstruction en
montrant qu'une autre politique est
possible que celle de l'augmentation de
la tva qui non seulement va frapper le
pouvoir d'achat des retraités des
salariés mais la gauche et la tête sur
le sujet quand valérie pécresse disait
qu'il n'y aurait pas de hausse des prix
mais oui parce que nicolas sarkozy
lui-même a expliqué qu'il instaurait la
mesure en octobre comme ça les gens à
les consommer entre maintenant et le
mois d'octobre et qu'ensuite
de fait il y aurait l'augmentation des
prix donc le raisonnement ne tient pas
évidemment qu'il va y avoir une baisse
du pouvoir d'achat une augmentation des
primes et en plus non seulement c'est
une tva anti sociale c'est à dire c'est
une mesure d'injustice mais en plus
c'est une erreur économique très grave
déjà que la croissance est complètement
atone on est à 0,5 pour cent de
prévision pour 2012 et je crains que ce
soit une mesure qui va nous précipiter
dans la dans la récession puisque en
réduisant encore la consommation des
ménages
derrière ce sont les carnets de
commandes des entreprises ce sont la
situation des commerçants des artisans
qui va être mise en danger l'entreprise
doit donc y aurons un peu moins de
charges patronales ça c'est peut-être
c'est infinitésimal
et on voit bien que ce n'est pas avec
cette petite baisse de charges qu'on va
être alignée j'allais dire sur les
salaires qui sont pratiqués en chine où
le coût du travail en chine donc cette
idée qu'il faut baisser le coût du
travail pour rendre l'économie française
plus compétitive est complètement
absurde parce qu'on ne peut pas
s'aligner sur le pays du travail en
france
non je pense qu'il ya un problème de
compétitivité mais ce que propose
françois hollande dans son projet dans
ses 60 engagement pour la france c'est
un parc un pacte productif c'est à dire
d'investir d'aider nos pme avec une
banque publique pour les pme avec une
fiscalité différenciée pour les petites
entreprises et pour les grandes
entreprises avec un piètre ans et a déjà
un nom avec des eaux et du tout pas du
tout demander aujourd'hui demander aux
chefs d'entreprise aujourd'hui les
difficultés qu'ils rencontrent avec le
secteur bancaire qui sont immenses parce
que les banques aujourd'hui ne font plus
leur métier elles ne veulent plus
prendre de risques pour le financement
de notre économie
il y à aussi de nombreuses propositions
nicolas sarkozy et les mains sur oseo
nicolas sarkozy a annoncé la création
d'une filiale pour oséo
oui c'est à dire il veut copier l'idée
de françois hollande tout en la
déformant et en faisant autre chose
puisque ce qu'il annonce c'est
d'ailleurs la troisième fois qu'il
annonce la création de ce dispositif
nicolas sarkozy ce que personne n'a
relevé il l'avait déjà annoncé au mois
de septembre
donc il a toujours rien fait en
attendant les chefs d'entreprise ont des
problèmes ce qu'il annonçait une filiale
supplémentaires par rapport à oséo alors
que ce que propose françois hollande
c'est de regrouper tous les dispositifs
existants oseo la caisse des dépôts les
fonds régionaux et en proximité dans les
régions d'avoir une sorte de guichet
unique bancaire pour les chefs
d'entreprises pour leur permettre tout
de suite d'accompagner leurs projets et
notamment leur investissement puisque la
solution y compris par rapport aux
délocalisations c'est d'aider les
entreprises
investissent en france qui produisent en
france qui ont des projets stratégiques
dans des secteurs innovants comme par
exemple celui de la croissance verte où
on a laissé par exemple se défaire
complètement l'industrie française dans
le domaine des énergies photovoltaïques
donc il ya vraiment beaucoup de choses à
faire dans quand même dans toutes ces
mesures que vous allez voir défiler à
l'assemblée d'ici le 9 mars si on a une
peut-être qui va tous vous mettre
d'accord c'est la taxe sur les
transactions financières ou la voix très
nous attendons de voir si c'est celle
que nous avons proposé neuf fois et
contre laquelle l'ump a voté neuf fois
depuis le début de la législature bien
sûr que nous la voterons nous n'avons
nous sommes pas là dans des calculs
politiciens
ce que je crains c'est qu'en fait il
s'agit simplement de rétablir le timbre
de bourse sur les différentes
transactions que nicolas sarkozy avait
supprimée au 1er janvier 2008
donc c'est pas réellement ce qu'on
appelle la taxe tobin c'est à dire la 7
0 20% à 10 j'attends de voir le texte
qui sera déposé le 8 février
on a beaucoup entendu les députés
socialistes sur cette tva sociale
un peu moins sur les accords
compétitivité emploi qui permettent de
moduler en fait le temps de travail en
fonction de l'activité du moment de
l'entreprise est-ce que ça c'est une
bonne mesure un système qui a fait ses
preuves d'une sorte de chômage là du
tout on nous entend beaucoup sur cette
tva anti sociale parce que c'est le
symbole de la justice et qu au contraire
aujourd'hui il faudrait mettre fin à
beaucoup de privilèges fiscaux et de
cadeaux fiscaux mais en effet ces
accords sont une forme de chantage en
fait c'est à dire qu'on voit bien on l'a
vu d'ailleurs dans un certain nombre
d'entreprises cette logique où on dit
aux salariés et bien il faut que vous
acceptiez de travailler moins pour
gagner moins il faut vous acceptez que
parfois la vérité que vos salaires
baissent j'essaie d'être immérité il
peut arriver que
une entreprise et de réelles difficultés
et besoins d'avoir - oui donc ça se sont
pas travailler ce sont par exemple les
mesures sur le chômage partiel qui ont
tardé à être prise ou moi je ne dis pas
qu'il ya pas des dispositifs
transitoires de crise à prévoir mais là
ce n'est pas ça c'est une sorte de
système qui va permettre une
modification unilatérale du contrat de
travail des ouvriers des salariés sans
qu'on leur demande réellement leur avis
donc je pense que c'est une régression
sociale
la cfdt s'est dit ouverte à la
discussion sur ce thème il a écouté on
verra ce que cela donne en tout cas en
catimini cette semaine l'ump a fait
voter un amendement qui donc qu'on
tourne tout dispositif de négociations
sociales avec les syndicats et qui
prévoit qu' il puisse y avoir une
modification unilatérale du contrat de
travail d'un salarié sans recueillir
l'accord du salarié par rapport à 7
cette modification donc c'est une
régression sociale aller à l'occasion de
son interview télévisée dimanche nicolas
sarkozy a également beaucoup cité l
allemagne je vous propose un petit
florilège
écoutez je prends l'exemple de
l'allemagne
l'allemagne est notre premier client
l'allemagne chez notre partenaire qu'en
france ya plus de jeunes au chômage
qu'en allemagne
en allemagne il ya trois fois plus de
jeunes en apprentissage qu'en france
l'allemagne et de tous les pays d'europe
le sol qui non seulement a gardé ses
emplois industriels
mais les a développées que font les
allemands enfin une bonne nouvelle pour
l'allemagne alors delphine batho
l'allemagne c'est vraiment l'exemple à
suivre
françois hollande lui croit en la france
donc nous pouvons être dans une relation
d'amitié avec notre partenaire
historique dans la construction
européenne mais ça doit être une
relation d'égalité
l'allemagne la france n'a pas ressemblé
à devenir l'allemagne ni l'allemagne à
devenir la france la convergence n'est
pas nécessaire non je trouve que ce qui
est frappant dans ce dans ce florilège
de déclarations c'est cette impression
là que le président de la république
sortant ne croit plus à la france notre
pays est une grande nation la france a
des atouts elle a des savoir faire elle
a des choses à apporter à l'économie
européenne
là des choses à apporter sur la scène
internationale notamment des valeurs qui
sont toujours celles que défend notre
pays donc je trouve ça un peu
préoccupant cette façon d'abaisser en
permanence la france sans vous dites
c'est notre partenaire historique le
traité européen a été signé cette
semaine qui prévoit notamment la règle
d'or est ce que françois hollande s'il
arrive au pouvoir
respectera ce traité le fera ratifié par
le parlement en l'état non il l'a dit
très clairement qu'il souhaite
renégocier ce traité qui tant qu'il
n'est pas ratifié la question est
ouverte et il souhaite que l'élection
présidentielle soit l'occasion pour les
français d'agir comme un levier pour
peser dans la construction européenne
sur le fond quel est le problème de ce
traité il y à la demande d'un sérieux et
d'une discipline budgétaire
là dessus les engagements de françois
hollande sont claires puisqu'il propose
le retour aux 3% de déficit public en
2013 l'equilibre sur la durée du
quinquennat c'est à dire en deux et en
2017 et il propose pour cela une loi de
programmation pluriannuelle du retour à
l'équilibré des finances publiques ce
qui n'est pas exactement la règle d'or
constitutionnelle mais ce qui est une
forme de discipline budgétaire tel que
nos partenaires européens peuvent
l'exiger
et donc il ya là une garantie de sérieux
ce qui ne va pas dans ce traité c'est
qu'il n'y a strictement rien sur la
croissance c'est comme si on voulait que
advitam eternam la politique européenne
soit une politique d'austérité et le
problème c'est que l'austérité ça
aggrave la crise l'austérité ça ne
permet pas de résoudre le problème de la
dette et des déficits au contraire ça
aggrave la situation donc les dettes
augmentent comme les dettes augmente les
taux d'intérêt augmentent donc ça
augmente les dettes et vous voyez on est
dans une classe de l'affairé ce ne se
décrétant pas ça veut dire qu'il faut
effectivement continue dans une
politique de déficit malgré tout il ya
comme une contradiction non c'est à dire
qu'il faut le système d euro bond cela
veut dire qu'il faut des grands
chantiers européen d'infrastructures
dans le dos mais je ne veux absolument
pas donc on va quand même se heurter
est-ce que c'est madame merkel qui
décide de tout pour les français non il
faut discuter une relation de
partenariat naissant des fois que la
part de nicolas sarkozy d'avoir essayé
de la faire prier que ça plaise pas vrai
voyez puisque nicolas sarkozy au mois
d'août dernier il a accepté de ne plus
demander la mise en place des euro bond
sur lesquels un certain nombre d'autres
partenaires européens étaient favorables
à cette idée et d'ailleurs quand la
france a perdu son triple a de nouveau
un certain nombre de partenaires
européens ont dit quand même il faudrait
vraiment faire ces eurobonds donc c'est
la demande de françois hollande qui
souhaite que le traité européen soit
complétée sur sur ce point là et tant
que ce traité n'est pas ratifié il est
tout à fait possible de le renégocier
si on revient sur la proximité nicolas
sarkozy angela merkel c'est quand même
un atout pour lui on sait qu'elles
veulent soutenir dans sa campagne il y
aura d'ailleurs une interview télévisée
à la fois sur la zdf et sur france 2
lundi prochain de nicolas sarkozy et
angela merkel
ce que c'est à dire que neuf chaînes de
dimanche dernier n'ont pas n'ont pas
suffi je faisais un trait d'humour mais
on voit bien on est dans une forme de
politique spectacle avec nicolas sarkozy
en permanence le soutien d'angela merkel
c'est un handicap points à tous vos
pensées à ce que c'est une surprise la
droite européenne et est uni
c'est elle d'ailleurs qui a tenu la
plume de ce traité européen que nous
voulons renégocier c'est déjà arrivé
d'ailleurs que des dix d'autres des
dirigeants d'autres pays s'engagent aux
côtés de responsables politiques
français dans les campagnes électorales
j'espère simplement qu'elle le frein
avec un peu de réserve et de retenue et
je suis pas certaine à la vérité que ce
soit un calcul politique profitable à
nicolas sarkozy allez on ce mardi
toujours et avant les questions au
gouvernement les députés et sénateurs de
la majorité avaient été conviés à
l'elysée à ce qu'on appelle désormais à
la fameuse séance de calinothérapie qui
s'est visiblement mu est plutôt en
sévère recadrage en tout cas à la sortie
certains ceux qui voulaient bien parler
avait l'air revigoré tu es très en forme
il a présenté ses propositions avec ses
convictions nous a dit qu'en avec le
sourire dont il s'est fait preuve c'est
faire preuve pardon que le moment venu
et bien il se déclarait qu'il avait très
envie d'aller à la rencontre des
français
il nous a dit que
il était sûrement le suicidaire le plus
en forme de france il a dit que
finalement il y aurait le temps de la
campagne certes mais aujourd'hui le
temps un lac est à l'action je crois
qu'il y en a toujours qui sont
dubitatifs mais il faut faire taire nos
différents un moment pour la
contestation il ya un moment pour
l'union
c'était le moment pour l'union qui était
arrivé vous qu'il ait côtoyé dans
l'hémicycle vous en l'air un peu
démoralisés un peu déboussolé aux
collègues de la majorité
honnêtement oui oui honnêtement oui
parce que je pense que les
parlementaires qui sont sur le terrain
dans les circonscriptions savent qu'il y
à un rejet très profond de nicolas
sarkozy et de sa politique dans le pays
quand vous dégoûter le problème pour
nous si vous voulez ce n'est pas de
commenter
aujourd'hui ce rejet c'est d'offrir une
solution au peuple français de proposer
un changement de proposer des solutions
nouvelles et pas simplement c'est ce que
propose françois hollande c'est à dire
proposer un projet il faut susciter une
adhésion une confiance et pas simplement
miser sur le rejet de nicolas sarkozy
qu'est vraiment le président on vous a
offert un boulevard finalement en
annonçant une hausse de la tva comme ça
à quelques semaines de l'élection
présidentielle
comment vous expliquez cette stratégie
est aussi s'il en a une je crois que
c'est une stratégie d'improvisation mois
le sentiment vraiment que j'ai
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
d'instabilité
des hésitations du côté de nicolas
sarkozy par rapport à servas son entrée
en campagne à son calendrier
il y en a parlé d'un suicide politique
c'est votre sentiment aussi sur les
états d'âme qui lie voilà juste y aura
un jour il avait état d'âme le lendemain
et dit qu'il en a pas on est dans une
forme d'improvisation permanente
donc nous ne faisons pas en relation
dans les serres dans les sondages
puisque françois hollande a dépassé la
barre des 30 points vous savez il ya les
sondages et puis il ya les élections
donc nous nous ne faisons pas en
fonction de nicolas sarkozy françois
hollande maîtrise son calendrier
présente sa candidature présente ses
propositions et la question du candidat
sortant de quand il se déclare de sa
stratégie n'est pas la nôtre
par contre on voit bien que vous
m'interrogez sur le choix de la tva
sociale il ya une toute une tentative de
faire passer cela pour des mesures
courageuses et moi je crois au contraire
c'est d'une grande lâcheté de s'en
prendre au pouvoir d'achat des français
et ne jamais s'en prendre
aux plus privilégiés aux plus fortunés
de ne jamais faire la réforme bancaire
ne jamais faire la réforme fiscale
je pense que ce sera non seulement c'est
pas du courage c'est une forme de
lâcheté
ce sont des mesures impopulaires mais
nécessaires qui ont bien profité à des
longs thiembronne en angleterre par
exemple non ce n'est pas des mesures
nécessaires ce n'est pas vrai ce sont
des mesures qui vont aggraver la
situation de l'économie française
allez on va continuer l'actualité avec
une invitée surprise au sénat marine le
pen alors que les militants du front
national sont restés à l'extérieur
l'avocat gilbert collard se chargeant
d'haranguer la foule sur le thème des
500 signatures
la présidente du fn s'est rendu dans
l'hémicycle pour soutenir le sénateur
non inscrit jean louis masson qui
propose de rendre anonymes le parrainage
des mères aux candidats à l'élection
présidentielle paul bouffard les aura
les aura pas en attendant marine le pen
manifestent pour réclamer l'anonymat des
parrainages d'élus pour la
présidentielle devant le sénat et devant
quelques militants elle dénonce ce
système il est largement temps de sens
et cette modalité qui consiste à livrer
en réalité la liste des noms des mères à
la vindicte de quelques milices
d'extrême gauche ou aux pressions de
quelques oligarques ump ou socialiste
une manifestation pour soutenir jean
louis masson le sénateur de la moselle
propose l'anonymat pour lutter contre la
pression des grands partis selon le
sénateur
le système n'est plus démocratique il ya
eu deux maires qui ont été confrontés à
des menaces à du chantage et à des
pressions tout à fait inadmissible donc
il faut savoir si on est en république
est en démocratie ou si aussi en
fonctionne comme au sénégal comme en
egypte du temps de moubarak ou en russie
du temps de poutine à l'association des
maires de france au contraire le
parrainage ouvert est une garantie de
crédibilité l'anonymat serait dangereux
est normal que les mecs sont des hommes
et des femmes qui parraine le fasse sans
doute tarte et toute transparence
vis-à-vis de leur conscience
mais pas seulement il avait de la
population aujourd'hui sept français sur
dix souhaitent que marine le pen puisse
se présenter la candidate peine pourtant
à obtenir ces signatures à l'ump ou au
ps on crie au bluff
selon eux le front national j'aurai la
même partition à chaque élection pour
attirer les caméras lors d'un film bat
west pour revenir sur ce système des
parrainages et lever l'anonymat
ce n'est pas la question qui est posée
il ya une règle nous la respectons et en
effet on peut être dubitatif aujourd'hui
puisque lors de chaque campagne
présidentielle le front national a fait
ce numéro du faux suspense ou du
feuilleton sur ont-ils les signatures ne
les ont-ils pas donc il ya elle toujours
soulevé un doute lorsqu'aujourd'hui
madame le pen dit j'ai un problème avec
mes signature puisque en 88 ans 95 en
2002 la famille le pen a été candidate à
l'élection présidentielle après avoir
fait exactement le même type de campagne
comment le conseil constitutionnel va
examiner la requête de marine le glen se
pose la question
le conseil national se prononce on peut
imaginer au delà de 2012 même finalement
à une levée de ce système et je refuse
d'entrer dans ce dans ce domaine règle
ça médias convenait quand même que ceux
parmi tous ces maires non inscrit qui
constitue une grande majorité des maires
de france il puisse y avoir des
pressions pour ne pas donner son
parrainage à untel ou untel et jeu cela
peut poser problème je ne crois je ne
crois pas je m'entende y avait la
pression la pression pas de menaces sur
les élus non je pense que tout ça est
une campagne qui est entretenue comme
lors de chaque élection présidentielle
est peut-être s'il ya un problème avec
les parrainages des mères c'est qu'il ya
peut-être un problème avec les idées de
l'extrême droite avec les élèves à
dominique de villepin dit la même chose
christine boutin du label des choses
qu'ils ont du mal à recueillir leurs
parraineurs élus de droite
oui oui nous écouter pour les élus de
gauche au problème il y avait une corde
idée nationale qui est celle de françois
hollande nous demandons au maire de
gauche de soutenir la candidature de
françois hollande et nous faisons avec
les règles
ce ne sont pas nous qui les avons fixée
c'est catastrophique pour la
représentation nationale si marine le
pen n'était pas présente
après le 16 mars il avait passé cinq
cents signatures donc vous me demandez
de faire de la politique fiction pour
l'instant écoutez nous verrons
une règle chacun doit la respecter c'est
ce n'est pas nous qui l'avons décidé je
comprends que ça puisse et
éventuellement l'objet d'un débat
j'observe c'est à chaque fois un débat
dans les quinze derniers jours de
l'année des dates qui sont fixés c'est
pas un débat qu'on a en début de
quinquennat ou que voilà c'est à chaque
fois le front national c'est à nous les
mc5 jean marie le pen n'est juste pas eu
en 1980 mais effectivement il les a eus
tout joué dans 88 ans 95 en 2002 c'est
pas là aujourd'hui
vous m'interrogez moi je ne sais pas si
c'est vrai qu'il ne manque qu il en
manque pas je n'ai pas d'information le
film batman team orapi de jean pierre
chevènement on a appris cette semaine
qu'il ne serait pas candidat
vous attendez à ce qu'ils soutiennent le
candidat hollande nous aimerions qu'ils
soient les uns courtiser un dennis de
young qui les dragons ayant
effectivement le camp le camp du
changement et le rassemblement à nos
côtés dès le premier tour nous avons
beaucoup de respect pour jean pierre
chevènement qui a apporté des idées sur
la question républicaine sur la question
industrielle sur la question européenne
je crois que beaucoup des sujets qui lui
tiennent à coeur sont aujourd'hui
présents dans les engagements que prend
françois hollande donc nous espérons oui
le rassemblement le plus large dès le
premier tour plus pour le personnage
politique qu'il représente que pour les
voix qu'il pourrait emmener puisqu'il
était est très peu crédible présentée 2
oui mais ce qu'ils voient c'est cette
idée de cette idée de rassemblement nous
sommes déjà rassemblé avec les radicaux
de jean michel baylet avec christiane
taubira c'était un des problèmes vous
savez qui avait conduit à l'élimination
de la gauche en 2002 du premier tour
d'avoir une division une dispersion
donc nous nous voulons un rassemblement
dès le 1er tour aller mercredi c'est le
grand oral à des candidats à la
présidentielle sur le thème du mal
logement
ils ont été auditionnés par la fondation
abbé pierre qui les a invités à signer
un contrat social la fondation abbé
pierre qui présente donc son rapport
annuel sur le mal-logement elle profite
du contexte pour interpeller les
candidats sur une nouvelle politique
dans ce domaine en ce mercredi
ils sont quatre candidats a signé le
contrat social de la fondation thomas
sourire ils sont quatre quatre candidats
à la présidentielle qui s'engagent sur
le logement en cas de victoire en mai
prochain
tous devront appliquer ce contrat social
de la fondation abbé pierre
un rapport choc qui préconise entre
autres la construction annuelle de 500
mille appartements ou maisons
ainsi qu'un encadrement des loyers ouais
il se trouve que j'ai déjà planté devant
les français le projet présidentiel ça
chrono
se retrouve aujourd'hui dans le contrat
que vient de proposer la fondation
l'abbé pierre donc après je te montrerai
touchés sont pas des promesses sont des
engagements
si depuis le début je vous dis que mon
caractère correspond à mon programme
il est clair que quand vous m'entendez
parler de réquisition vous savez que je
le ferai j'ai gardé un très mauvais
souvenir de la signature du pacte
écologique de nicolas hulot parce que
tout le monde a signé après ceux qui
avaient signé les principaux samson
laver les mains est donc pour moi c'est
pas c'est pas du tout dans cet esprit
que je suis grand absent
nicolas sarkozy pas encore
officiellement candidat pour leur
présenter son conseiller henri guaino
venu vanter le bilan du chef de l'état
un président qui veut faire du logement
un des thèmes majeurs de la campagne
des paroles aux actes la fondation abbé
pierre attend toujours les preuves
moi j'attends de voir d'avoir rencontré
le président de la république avec nos
propositions pour voir si vraiment il ya
des divergences profondes et si ce qu'il
retient de notre code contrat social
durant tout le quinquennat
chaque mesure du futur président sera
scruté à la loupe tous les ans la
fondation abbé-pierre compte bien
réaliser le service après vente de son
contrat social vous avez entendu
françois bayrou est ce que comme le
pacte social en pacte écologique pardon
de 2007
ce projet ne va pas rester dans le
tiroir des bonnes intentions des
candidats ça dépend qui gagnera les
élections d'ici c'est françois hollande
qui est élu président de la république
il tiendra parole parce que françois
hollande tient aujourd'hui un discours
de vérité il n'est pas dans la
multiplication des formes des risques
beaucoup de chaque engagement avec le
programme du dialogue avec la fondation
abbé pierre avec la société civile vous
savez qu'il ya aujourd'hui un problème
considérable puisqu'il ya plus de 3
millions de personnes qui sont mal
logées ou très mal logées au pas logés
du tout qu'il y à une augmentation de
mal logement parce qu'il ya de la
spéculation foncière
donc il ya des communes qui ne veulent
pas construire de logements sociaux et
puis il ya une spéculation foncière qui
a été favorisée notamment par des
allègements fiscaux qui a conduit à une
inflation des prix considérables et la
mesure qui est proposée aujourd'hui par
nicolas sarkozy qui est absolument
absurde et ridicule d'augmenter encore
de 30% les possibilités de construction
sur un terrain va encore augmenter le
prix elle va encore augmenter la
spéculation foncière donc ça ne va pas
du tout résoudre les problèmes de
logements sur lesquels ce que propose
françois hollande
c'est un engagement sur la construction
de deux millions cinq cent mille
logements pendant le quinquennat
c'est un engagement qui est très
contesté d'ailleurs par la droite sur
l'encadrement des loyers dans les zones
où il ya eu les augmentations les plus
fulgurantes c'est le tollé contestée
parce qu'on dit que cela entraîne un
appauvrissement de l'offre de logements
ce qui est tout à fait probable
il faut bloquer non parce que je crois
qu'on est vraiment dans des dans des
territoires urbains là où il ya une
inflation telle qu'il faut prendre des
mesures
à chaque fois qu'il ya une nouvelle
location qui lie à une relocation il
faut empêcher cette flambée des loyers
s'est passé cite pas le propriétaire à
louer son logement
oui mais ça c'est le prétexte l'argument
1 depuis des années pour ne rien faire
il faut s'attaquer aussi au problème du
des cautions notamment pour les jeunes
il faut parce qu'il ya une question de
financement du logement social
ce que propose françois hollande c'est
aussi de doubler le plafond du livret à
de l'épargné populaire pour avoir ainsi
le financier pour favoriser la
construction et c'est aussi par rapport
à ce que vous disiez sur l'offre de
logement dans les grandes villes la
possibilité de transférer les terrains
de l'état aux collectivités qui
s'engageraient dans les cinq ans à
construire un certain nombre de
logements avec aussi la mixité sociale
c'est à dire la possibilité de d'avoir
cette règle des trois tiers logements
sociaux logements intermédiaires et
logements en accession à la propriété si
on revient la mesure d'augmenter de 30%
le droit à construire c'est un peu ce
que voulait faire bertrand delanoë à
paris aussi qu'on soit les tours plus
haute pour justement augmenter l'offre
de logements qui devraient avoir un
impact sur le prénom ce pas du tout ce
que voulait faire bertrand
l'anneau et qui d'ailleurs a eu un
échange assez vif hier avec le président
de la république sur sur cette question
puisque le président de la république
pointe et de façon totalement a justifié
la ville de paris qui elle demande
justement comme d'autres grandes villes
comme jean marc ayrault à nantes à avoir
cette possibilité d'avoir de récupérer
des terrains inutilisés par l'état pour
pouvoir engager la construction de
logements vous-même delphine batho vous
occuper un logement donc non
conventionnés un logement de la ville de
paris vous allez demander à payer un
surloyer quand vous avez été élu député
il faudrait que tous les politiques tous
les parlementaires fassent un peu de
ménage et fasse comme vous je ne sais
pas pour qu'on se comprenne bien je
n'habite absolument pas un logement
social un logement intermédiaire donc
oui moi j'ai voulu m'appliquer à des
principes que je considère comme
élémentaires tout en continuant à
habiter un quartier populaire et puis
françois hollande 1 se souviendra de la
signature de ce contrat social lors de
son paraphe le candidat socialiste a été
aspergé de farine par une lilloise qui
s'est approchée de lui avant d'être
fermement maîtrisée elle s'est déclaré à
bout de ressources
le principal c'est d'avoir délivré mon
message c'est quand tenté de dire
françois hollande un commentaire peut
être la fille de bateaux sur cette image
fait partie des péripéties d'une
campagne électorale je crois que
françois hollande a réagi avec un calme
assez assez impressionnant et il est
aujourd'hui dans cette volonté de même
si il a été question de sa sécurité la
halle ronde bien sûr une sécurité
normales mais il est dans cette volonté
c'est la sécurité a été renforcée à la
suite à ce qui était prévu donc c'est
maintenant il n'a rien à voir avec cette
péripétie
mais françois hollande veut garder un
contact normal direct et de proximité
avec les français avec les citoyens dans
cette campagne électorale même si il y à
des risques il veut garder ce contact ce
qu'on voit d'ailleurs il est aujourd'hui
dans la réalité
face à un adversaire nicolas sarkozy
qu'est dans la politique spectacle comme
on l'a appris quand on découvre que pour
un déplacement du président de la
république on a demandé à des ouvriers
qui ne travaillait pas de venir
de faire semblant de travailler françois
hollande n'est pas dans la mise en scène
et donc il veut garder une relation
directe un contact direct avec les
français même si hélas il y à ce type de
péripéties et d'ailleurs cette cette
femme je crois est aujourd'hui des
informations que j'ai eues dans la
presse en hôpital psychiatrique donc
voilà allez on continue avec toujours 1
ce mercredi nicolas sarkozy qui l'avait
promis et laurent wauquiez l'a fait le
ministre s'est rendu auprès des
ouvrières de lejaby à yssingeaux en
haute loire pour leur annoncer qu'une
solution avait été trouvée pour la
reprise de l'usiné transformé en atelier
de maroquinerie de luxe avec maintien
des 93 emplois
le symbole c'est que si jamais on se bat
on y arrive peut-être pas tout le temps
mais on peut arriver à montrer ici par
exemple que produire en france c'est
possible et que la france peut continuer
à défendre ses atouts avec donc un
carnet de commandes garantie par louis
vuitton lejaby c'est l'anti gandrange ce
sont les promesses tenues
c'est si ce qui est annoncé et vrai
parce que moi je suis un peu comme saint
thomas je ne crois que ce que je vois
donc j'espère que la parole qui est
prononcé va être tenu et que lorsqu on
reviendra dans six mois dans un an
ces ouvrières auront toujours du travail
c'est grâce à leur combat peut-être que
le gouvernement aussi a été stimulée par
la proche des échéances électorales par
le fait qu' arnaud montebourg nom de
françois hollande s'était rendu sur
place
donc tant mieux voilà franchement nous
n'allons pas faire la fine bouche si ces
emplois sont sauvés si les ouvrières ont
du travail tant on est un peu dans le
symbole un dans la politique un peu
spectacle parce qu'on met la lumière sur
cette entreprise là il y en a d'autres
bien d'autres il y en a d'autres et
c'est d'ailleurs ce que martine aubry a
dit à françois fillon et hier donc
j'espère que toutes les autres
entreprises où il ya aujourd'hui la
possibilité d'éviter des lots des
délocalisations ou de relocaliser une
production industrielle cela sera fait
moi dans ma circonscription dans les
deux sèvres vous voyez il y avait une
entreprise qui avait fermé dans le
secteur de la confection une entreprise
qui s'appelle chizé confection que les
ouvrières ont repris en scop en
coopératives et c'est une entreprise
aujourd'hui qui se porte très bien parce
que même dans le secteur de
l'habillement
et en particulier de la haute couture où
il ya des savoir faire français
et bien il y à cette recherche d'une
qualité du travail qui ne va pas vers
vous voyez la baisse du coût du travail
les salaires toujours plus bas mais qui
va vers au contraire un travail soigné
de qualité faits par des ouvrières en
france en vous croyez au made in france
c'est beau je crois plus que jamais
effectivement à la relocalisation des
activités industrielles dans bien des
domaines où nous avons des savoir faire
ou donc ce qui fait notre différence
c'est la valeur ajoutée que nous pouvons
apporter sur un certain nombre de
produits pour cela ça veut dire que
toutes les aides aux entreprises tous
les financements tout doit être
conditionné à cette localisation de la
production en france
et puis dans la série des bonnes
nouvelles de la semaine il est aussi le
rafale avec l'inde qui commanderait 126
exemplaires pour un montant de 12
milliards de dollars
le contrat n'est pas encore signé il y à
un brassard 8e rafale qui seront
construits en inde
est-ce qu'on peut quand même redouter
dans ce cas là un transfert des
technologies
oui d'abord si ces contrats sont
finalisés ce sera une bonne nouvelle et
ce sera d'autant plus une bonne nouvelle
que le déficit du commerce extérieur de
la france qui était de 30 milliards
lorsque nicolas sarkozy est devenu
président de la république en 2007
atteint aujourd'hui plus de 70 milliards
donc tant mieux si ces contrats sont
finalisés mais c'est vrai qu'il y a pour
tous les spécialistes des industries de
défense à un risque qui est celui de
transfert de technologie c'est à dire
que en étant les premiers ces contrats
seraient en quelque sorte les derniers
donc il faut être particulièrement
vigilant à les jeudis duel télévisé
entre le premier ministre françois
fillon et la première secrétaire du
parti socialiste martine aubry
une semaine après le débat entre alain
juppé et françois hollande
un autre débat était très attendu celui
opposant martine aubry première
secrétaire du ps au premier ministre
françois fillon
une affiche alléchante qui n'a cependant
pas tenu toutes ses promesses
résumé de mounir souci confort martine
aubry est la bienvenue
asseyez-vous bonsoir monsieur point
ministre bonjour madame
quand un premier ministre une première
secrétaire se retrouvent face à face
cela donne un débat de premier de la
classe
françois fillon et martine aubry avait
bien fait leurs devoirs avant cette
confrontation
une discussion technique sur les moyens
de réduire les déficits et doper la
compétitivité face à martine aubry
françois fillon déroulé dépens les
dernières propositions du président de
la république la hausse de 1,6 point de
la tva n'aura quasiment aucun effet sur
les prix pourquoi
d'abord parce que 60% de la consommation
des ménages s'est pas la tva à 19,6
c'est les taux de tva intermédiaire
après un nouvel hommage au modèle
allemand décidément en vogue la
politique reprend ses droits dans les
dernières minutes
je voulais vous poser simplement une
question quand la france a été montré du
doigt avec le discours de dakar qui a
humilié l'afrique quand elle a été
montrée du doigt y compris par le pape
avec le discours de grenoble qui a
stigmatisé les étrangers
particulièrement les roms
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ces
discours de dakar et de promenade
le premier ministre reste solidaire du
chef de l'état durant l'émission martine
aubry a cité à l'envi le nom de françois
hollande test de loyauté réussi pour ces
deux personnalités qui se sont affrontés
sont vraiment ce livre est ce que
martine aubry est dans la short list
pour succéder peut-être à françois
fillon comme premier ministre si
françois hollande est élu
alors je vais vous donner un scoop nous
n'avons pas encore gagné les élections
donc toute composition du gouvernement
n'est absolument pas à l'ordre du jour
et serait complètement prématurée nous
sommes aujourd'hui en campagne
électorale il reste encore 79 jours nous
voulons mériter la confiance des
français donc nous sommes dans un jour
dans ce genre de confrontation il gagne
ses galons très clairement oui mais
aujourd'hui nous sommes
complètement unis donc c'est vrai si
vous me posez la question qu'aujourd'hui
françois hollande à la force de tout le
travail préparatoire qui l'a fait avant
d'être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle il a la force de ces
propositions de ses capacités
personnelles et là aussi la force d'une
équipe sur laquelle il s'appuie dans
laquelle il y à martine aubry mais aussi
d'autres responsables elle est la
première secrétaire du parti socialiste
dont qu'elle joue pleinement son rôle
dans cette campagne mais nous ne sommes
pas encore une fois dans des calculs
complètement prématuré je rends gens
lisaient dans certains journaux sur des
compositions ou n'importe quel qu'il
soit même corde insolent ne serait pas
contre nommer une femme à matignon est
ce que vous confirmez
je pense que je vous ai répondu on est
absolument pas vraiment dans cet état
d'esprit aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas
encore gagné l'élection présidentielle
bien sûr si françois hollande est
président de la république je vous le
confirme il y aura un gouvernement il y
aura un premier ministre mais nous ne
sommes pas aujourd'hui dans des
distributions de rôle pour les uns et
les autres nous n'avons pas encore gagné
les shadow cabinet à l'avance doré au
fini avec cette opération séduction de
nicolas sarkozy cela se passe pendant
les voeux à la presse le président
utilise la métaphore du couple pour
définir ses rapports avec les
journalistes
extrait je vois bien vos tentatives pour
me remplacer
pour essayer autre chose pour voir de
nouveaux horizons pour espérer pour
respirer ailleurs les remet toujours
plus verte
jusqu'à présent vous êtes toujours fait
et je vois même comme avait il eu
l'homme de l'année 2011 j'espère que
c'est pas pour vous débarrasser 2012
françois hollande n'est pas le seul à
savoir manier l'humour même si je
transmets réel oui et nous ne manque pas
d'humour tout de même i7 séduire ce sont
ses interlocuteurs un sujet dont il a
pas parlé lors de ses voeux à la presse
c'est la liberté de la presse c'est
l'indépendance des médias
on a quand même appris qu'on a un
directeur central du renseignement
intérieur mis en examen pour avoir
espionné les communications
téléphoniques d'un journaliste du
journal le monde qui travaillaient sur
l' affaire woerth bettencourt
donc je trouve ça un petit peu cette
légèreté je la trouve un peu étonnante
ou déplacés est-ce qu'il faut qu'il
mette un terme rapidement au suspense
julien d'encore qui entoure sa
candidature mais qui croient qu'ils
aient le moindre suspense c'est un faux
suspense personne n'a aucun doute
d'ailleurs lui même lorsqu'il y a des
doutes visiblement convoque en
catastrophe tous les parlementaires de
droite à l'elysée pour leur faire des
piqûres de ciment donc je ne crois pas
qu'ils aient le moindre doute sur la
candidature du candidat sortant non
déclarés il ya une sorte de faux système
de faux suspense qui est une sorte de
stratégie de communication puisque
nicolas sarkozy en permanence et dans la
communication dans la politique
spectacle donc on annonce que la
dernière stratégie c'est qu'il va encore
dire qu'il a changé qu'il va avoir des
formes de regrets je pense que c'est pas
très sérieux à à moins de 80 jours
maintenant du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle me delphine batho merci
beaucoup vous êtes venu avec le petit
prochain oui
selon leur entrée j'ai distribué à 15
millions de retrouver sur les marchés
sur mon les marchés dans les lieux de
deux les occasions de rencontres dans
les gares et dans les programmes les
marques anglaises sur les communes
rurales alors merci beaucoup d'amour et
c'est avec nous et nous delphine on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine merci au
revoir